après nuit depuis intense la patience et
demi ce matin beaucoup de patience
ce conducteur n'a pas bougé d'un poil
depuis plus d'une heure
2 depuis le début des inondations il y a
deux semaines ça prend plus de temps
pour se déplacer mais aujourd'hui c'est
pire encore lance-t-il
même scénario ici
il n'y a aucune autre option pour ce
camionneur qui doit traverser la
province
les communautés à l'aise date butoir
sont très très difficile d'accès
l'autoroute transcanadienne fermé en
raison des inondations la seule autre
option c'est la route 7 ici les ce matin
il ya eu un glissement de terrain puis
un accident de voiture résultat la route
est partiellement fermé on est bloqués
ici depuis plus de deux heures
pendant que toute la région est
immobilisé le pasteur de l'église ghetto
et lui s'active au début des inondations
il a transformé son église en banque
alimentaire
depuis des dizaines de bénévoles se
succèdent pour gérer les opérations
bouygues attend nous avons interpellé
les membres de la communauté sur
facebook qui nous avons reçu des tonnes
de dans
un élan de fraternité qui apaise
l'anxiété des sinistrés comme christy
sous un ordre d'évacuation la mère de
famille a dû tout abandonner il ya deux
semaines et se réfugier chez de la
famille avec son mari et ses trois
enfants
c'est angoissant parce qu'on a trois
jeunes enfants et on n'est plus dans
notre maison ils sont très émotifs
le pasteur est inquiet alors que plus de
pluie est attendue ce soir et ce
week-end son équipe et lui travaille
sans arrêt
il souhaite donner un peu d'ail des
d'espoir en espérant que tous passeront
à noël les pieds au sec ici ils disent à
céret radio canada abbotsford